[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi consacrée aux
jobs d'été et au job saisonnier tout de
suite le sommaire à saint quentin en
yvelines les opportunités d'emploi sont
nombreux durant la saison estivale mais
aussi en septembre avec l'arrivée la
ryder cup des emplois destinés notamment
aux plus jeunes ils profitent de cette
période pour acquérir une première
expérience professionnelle comme nous
l'expliquera laurence cousin directrice
d'une information jeunesse à nous vous
emmènerons également à france miniature
à la proche de la saison estivale le
parc d'attractions situé à elancourt à
renforcer son effectif agents d'accueil
polyvalent ou encore agent espaces verts
focus sur ces métiers saisonniers la
course aux jobs d'été a débuté il ya
maintenant à quelques mois saint quentin
en yvelines les secteurs qui recrutent
durant cette période sont nombreux et
des emplois liés notamment aux sports
comme vous allez le voir à travers ce
reportage
les images sont signés michael almy
d'euros c'est quasiment un passage
obligé pour une bonne partie des
étudiants les jobs d'été
les raisons sont multiples financer un
projet de vacances ou avoir une première
expérience professionnelle
parmi les possibilités travailler en
centre de loisirs ou encore dans des
enseignes de bricolage à montigny le
bretonneux cette enseigne d'équipement
sportif compte une vingtaine de salariés
chacun son domaine le textile ou encore
le sport urbain une équipe renforcée
pendant la saison estivale
une période durant laquelle se déroule
notamment les soldes chaque département
est géré par un responsable
et du coup en fonction des besoins du
responsable ça peut augmenter de 2 à 3
personnes par département pour la mode
des sols alors ce sont des étudiants
généralement chez go sport nous
recrutons des personnes avec qui nous
avons travaillé en stage donc c'est déjà
juste une récompense par rapport au
travail qui a été fourni en amont pour
pouvoir les récompensés par un job d'été
les contrats proposés par les enseignes
sont des cdd de deux ou trois mois
aucune formation particulière n'est
demandée après c'est sûr qu'il faut
avoir des qualités indéniables comme
neutre bien sûr le contact avec le
client
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est quand même
au quotidien face à des clients et après
on demande juste d'être un passionné de
sport même si on n'exerce pas ça nous
permettra en fait d'être en colère en
corrélation avec les demandes et les
attentes de nos clients et pour celles
et ceux qui préféraient profiter de
leurs vacances d'été il reste le mois de
septembre pour travailler la tenue de la
ryder cup à saint quentin en yvelines va
offrir de nombreuses opportunités
d'emplois saisonniers
que ce soit dans le domaine de la
sécurité ou encore dans le domaine de la
restauration conseiller et aider les
jeunes dans leur recherche d'emploi pour
la période estivale c'est la mission
divine information jeunesse
nous avons rencontré sa directrice
laurence cousin laurence coût d'un
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
divine information jeunesse alors le
rôle de votre structure s'est notamment
de renseigner les jeunes y vit moins sur
les opportunités d'emploi notamment les
opportunités qui peuvent trouver durant
la saison estivale
alors durant la saison estivale on
entend parler de jobs d'été on entend
parler également de contrats saisonniers
quelle est la différence c'est la même
chose en fait sauf que contrat
saisonnier c'est plus générique ça veut
dire qu'un contrat saisonnier c'est
pendant une saison que ça peut être
l'été principalement on en voit souvent
mais apple est également aussi et la
saison d'hiver
en fait tout simplement alors ce sont
des contrats qui dure combien de temps
général ont justement c'est vraiment à
quoi faut il faut que les jeunes pensent
c'est la durée de leur disponibilité
c'est vrai quelques fois ils veulent
financer des vacances par exemple ça
qu'un gel qui disponibles que quinze
jours ça est très compliqué pour lui
trouver un emploi saisonnier
donc quand on leur conseille un mois
minimum pour pour que en fait
l'employeur est aussi des bénéfices
aille à avoir un jeune sur un premier
emploi un premier job
or à partir de quel âge on peut
travailler l'été alors légalement ne
peut travailler à partir de l'âge de 16
ans mais c'est vrai qu'il ya la théorie
et la pratique comme on dit et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué pour un jeune
mineur de trouver un emploi saisonnier
même s'il est moins payé
aucun abattement sur le taux du smic on
leur donne toutes ces informations là on
a un gi trouve un job qui leur donne des
informations aussi sur la législation
les contrats de travail l'âge légal les
indemnités les rémunérations mais mais
c'est vrai que c'est plus compliqué leur
conseille notamment de faire fonctionner
leurs réseaux parce que c'est quand on
connaît un jeune prouver son sérieux sa
disponibilité éventuellement ses
compétences
si son formation de professionnels
notamment panne on les accompagne pour
l'élaboration du cv dans les scènes de
mettre en avant leur savoir être leur
savoir faire si on vous parlait
justement de rémunération alors on va
dire pour un jeune qui est majeur qui a
qu'à 18 ans la rémunération pour un job
d'été sais c'est quoi c'est le smic
minimum c'est le smic minimum exactement
voilà on est vraiment sur un contrat de
travail classique en fait tout à fait
alors sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines quelles sont les
opportunités de jobs d'été
on peut faire je sais pas un top 5 par
exemple des métiers qui recrutent saison
alors jobs d'été déjà si vous voulez
c'est pour des jeunes qui n'ont pas
toujours l'expérience donc il faut que
ce soit des des emplois qu'ils soient
accessibles on ne demande pas des
compétences incroyable puisque
effectivement un jeune voilà il peut
c'est pas forcément son futur métier
donc nous par exemple on a beaucoup de
nos forum jobs d'été tout ce qui va être
hôtesse autotests en entreprise pour
remplacer les salariés qui ont des coûts
gdt on accueille aussi l'organisation
régionale de l'agriculture pour tout ce
qui est que iata cueillir dans toute la
france donc ça c'est vraiment accessible
donc c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup ça
peut être le tertiaire ça peut être le
terreau et restauration envoyez-la déjà
un top3 qui sert glissement place au
commerce et bien sûr évidemment
ça peut être aussi tout ce qui va être
le comptage dans les transports en
commun les inventaires dans les
hypermarchés
ça peut être aussi pour un jeune
courageux d'aller faire les marchés
d'aller demander s'il ya besoin et
d'aller faire des marchés pendant la
semaine même pendant l'été en bord de
mer pas voyez en fait à la voilà l'idée
c'est aussi de voir les critères est ce
qu ils veulent rester sur place et se
faire de l'argent
est ce qu ils veulent aussi allier un
peu de tourisme et partir un peu plus
loin et donc on discute avec eux et on
voit en fonction mais les possibilités
qui peuvent avoir
et comme je devais on a un biais de scie
qui peuvent télécharger sur le site mais
qu'on peut leur donner qui permet par
secteur d'activité de répertorier
justement les secteurs et aussi les
sites internet où ils peuvent avoir des
offres alors une dernière question on
est mi juin
est-ce qu'il est trop tard pour trouver
un job d'été les jeunes qui nous
regardent
est ce que est ce que c'est trop tard
pour eux ce sera pour l'année prochaine
alors il n'est jamais trop tard mais
c'est vrai que en général par exemple
notre réseau nous forum jobs d'été ont
lieu en mars avril mai
exceptionnellement et des grandes
entreprises commencent à recruter en
emploi saisonnier a dès janvier-février
1 donc il ya forcément les désistements
des revenus donc le dernière minute ça
peut ça peut être une possibilité ça
peut être aussi les agences d'intérim
ça peut être son réseau encore une fois
faut miser sur la disponibilité si vous
êtes disponible que d'un mois mais là je
pense qu'il peut y avoir encore des
opportunités mais il faudra se dépêcher
quand même merci de laurence présent
parce que ces renseignements je rappelle
que vous êtes directrice d'yveline
information jeunesse
je vous propose à présent de prendre la
direction a des longs courts et plus
précisément du parc france miniature
ouvert de fin mars à début novembre
l'équipe est composée en grande majorité
de saisonniers reportage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
découvrir ou redécouvrir le patrimoine
français de façon ludique bienvenue à
france miniature
ce parc situé à elancourt met en scène
son 17 maquette
à cela s'ajoutent des attractions une
boutique ou encore des points de
restauration en saison jusqu'à 60
collaborateurs travaillent ici sébastien
diaz bonjour bonjour vous êtes agent
artistique ici à france miniature alors
c'est vous qui avez la charge en fait
que ce parc de 5 ha soit entretenu c'est
ça absolument
voilà je gère trois services en fait les
espaces verts l'animation et la maquette
donc qu'une petite équipe de de cette
personne
on est deux permanents avec un
technicien qui s'occupe aussi des
services généraux et en embauche 5
personnes 2 en animation d'un espace
vert et une personne dans la maquette
donc qui ont un contrat saisonnier là et
qui sont des contrats variables certains
sont un peu plus court que d'autres mais
voilà on les emmène jusqu'à jusqu'à la
fin de la saison et on les embauche dès
le départ et même des fois un mois
- avant l'ouverture pour pour préparer
l'ouverture du parc
c'est quoi une journée type ici à la
france miniature
la première chose que je fais c'est
fallait fouilles archéologiques donc
remettre le sahb en place remettre les
petits jeux dedans pour que les enfants
puissent trouver dans la journée après
je fais le tour du parc
je regarde je vérifie s'il ya des des
mises en scène devant les maquettes qui
sont tombés au jeu remet en place
il n'y a pas de pissenlit de mauvaises
herbes qui ont poussé entre temps jean
lève et je regarde aussi les cours d'eau
fait le tour des cours d'eau regarder
s'il ya des plastiques des papiers de
bonbons qui ont été jetés par les
enfants ou autres
qu'est ce qui vous plaît finalement dans
ce métier parce qu'il me plaît dans ce
métier parce qu'on est agent polyvalent
ont fait aussi bien du jardinage des
réparations et du nettoyage
on fait de tout alain bonjour arusha
vous êtes responsable des opérations est
ici en france miniature alors
responsable des opérations ça consiste
en quoi
alors c'est beaucoup de choses
à la fois la gestion que de la boutique
souvenir de l'accueil billetterie les
attractions de la partie reporting donc
tout ce qui est chiffre d'affaires est
remonté de deux chiffres en général les
visites guidées
combien de salariés travaillent au sein
de tous de tous ses pôles alors
on a une dizaine de salariés
entend enfin en saisonnier c'est à dire
qu'il faut une saison début d'ouverture
du parc donc appartement en mars
jusque fin novembre mi-novembre médias
voilà
ensuite on a des renforts qui s'ajoutent
à cela des contrats qui arrivent pendant
les périodes fortes donc les jours
fériés et vacances scolaires
donc là principalement des étudiants
m'excuse et des périodes très courtes
sinon le reste de mes saisonniers sur la
question on change de poste en poste à
peu près toutes les une ou deux heures
et on passe aux attractions on passe
dans le parc on pose des questionnaires
ont fait des visites guidées le matin le
plus souvent et après on encaisse
billetterie comme je veux lui dire ou à
la boutique souvent le soir alors ça
fait combien de temps que vous
travaillez ici en france moi là ça va
faire bientôt deux mois et demi à peu
près on a commencé un petit peu avant
l'ouverture de la bourse us effet le 31
mars 1 france miniature une ouverture
aux clients nous on est venu à peu près
deux semaines avant pour les formations
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans ce métier
alors pas le cadre déjà on ne peut pas
nier que travailler dehors au soleil la
plupart du temps c'est quand même très
agréable et dans des parcs d'attraction
ou d'un code dans des campings les gens
sont plus souriants
c'est les gens viennent passer un bon
moment d'autres souvent c'est bien plus
agréable de travailler dans cette
ambiance là
[Musique]
durant la saison estivale le parquet
donc pour toi devrait accueillir 190
mille visiteurs voilà vous en savez plus
sur les jobs d'été et les jobs
saisonniers et voici ce qu'il faut
retenir pour un job d'été ou un job
saisonnier vous saurez embauchés en
contrat intérim en contrat à durée
déterminée la rémunération c'est le
strict minimum si vous avez plus de 18
ans pour un job d'été aucune formation
spécifique n'est généralement demandé
par contre il faut être motivé cette
émission touche bientôt à sa fin mais
avant voyons ensemble les rendez vous
qui vous attendent à mardi 19 juin de 14
heures à 16 heures une réunion sur le
métier d'analyste en cybersécurité aura
lieu à la cité des métiers à trappes
inscription au 01 34 82 82 61 et puis
jeudi à 21 juin à partir de 9 heures une
réunion d'information sur les
opportunités d'emplois liées à la ryder
cup aura lieu en salle du conseil de
saint quentin en yvelines à cet attrape
si vous souhaitez participer une fois
envoyé un mail à l'adresse qui s'affiche
ape points 78 1121 @ paul tirer
emploi.fr
c'est la fin de ce numéro à merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi à 26
juin pour un mode d'emploi consacré à
l'innovation pédagogique
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]